um
[Music]
the
everyone
is
all of the public health measures that
are still interesting
will be with
and the evolution
what the next week
as a teacher
living with the virus means
that canadians shouldn't be dying
we cannot be dishonest
in front of these
is
will no longer
living with
living with the virus
[Music]
yes
is
i would like to address some of the
events that have marked the news this
week
a few days ago my colleague joelle
lightbaum held a press conference in
this very room
i have a considerable level of affection
and esteem for my dear friend joelle
we regularly discuss many issues
including the management of the pandemic
and i have always
valued and appreciated his input
in a democracy it's a healthy habit for
everyone to be able to express
his or her opinions
debate and discussion should always be
encouraged
we all know people who are eager to be
done with the pandemic
and to be honest we're all eager to be
done with with it
like joelle
i hear it at home in quebec city and
here certainly in ottawa
we also know that in order to get out of
this phase of kovid we must continue to
work together in experience in a spirit
of benevolence by joining our forces
against the virus
this is true for vaccination it's also
true for adherence to all the public
health measures that may still be in
place
for two years now our government's
actions in the fight against kobe 19
have been based on science and prudence
as we all know science is continuously
evolving and as we have done since the
beginning of the pandemic we will
continue to base our decisions on the
best available scientific information
and on prudence
now let's be clear
the public health restrictions currently
in place by provinces and territories in
particular were always meant to be
temporary
some of these restrictions will be with
us for a long time others will be lifted
as soon as the epidemiological situation
science and prudence allow it
that said it's important to keep in mind
that these measures are intended to
limit the harm caused by the virus the
virus
all measures are subject to constant
re-evaluation and we will continue to
adjust them according to science and
prudence and the evolution of the
epidemiological situation
with the worst of omicron now behind us
our government is actively reviewing the
measures in place at our borders and we
should be able to communicate changes on
this
next week with the support and the
advice of the team of dr tam
we would all like to know for sure what
the next few weeks and months have in
store for us but after two years of this
pandemic we know that this virus will
always find a way to surprise us
we know that the question is not whether
there will be other waves or variants
but rather
when
over the last few days we have hall
heard the phrase
we have to live with the virus
we all agree that we have to learn to
live with the virus but concretely
what does it mean to live with a virus
now let me humbly
suggest a couple of answers to that
question using perhaps a more
professorial tone
in
line with my earlier career in 2015 as a
professor of economics at university la
dal
firstly i would say that living with a
virus means that people have to stop
dying because of it in such large
numbers
secondly living with a virus means that
the virus in our health care system must
be able to coexist without the latter
being paralyzed
cancer patients being told that their
surgeries will have to wait because our
hospitals and our health care workers
are overwhelmed by corbyn 19.
thirdly
living with virus means that we must
individually and collectively optimize
the use the entire use of our tools in
our toolbox at our disposal to limit
transmission and the severity of
infections
fourthly living with a virus also means
that we must be honest with each other
and recognize that it's not only
possible but very likely that the coming
months will hold other unpleasant
surprises
fifthly
living with the virus means that we must
remember that we are not powerless in
that situation
we have power we can help ourselves and
we must keep helping each other
we have the power to make it so that the
public health restrictions imposed by
provinces and territories
are less severe and disrupt our social
life and our con and our economy as
little as possible
our main tool for that remains still and
always vaccination
even if we know that vaccination is
imperfect the science is unequivocal
vaccination does reduce transmission and
thus prevent severe complications
if we can prevent severe complications
our hospitals and healthcare workers
will not be overwhelmed
if our hospitals and health care workers
are not overwhelmed then in turn public
health restrictions will be less severe
it's obvious but it's important to
remember we have individually and
collectively the power to change things
living with kovid means that we must
exercise this power
that's the only way to reduce the impact
of the virus on our lives
finally
now that the worst of omicron is behind
us living with the virus means that we
should not wait for the next variant or
the next wave to
enhance our vaccination campaigns
we must continue to administer booster
doses pediatric doses as many as
possible including first second
and third doses so that when the next
wave or next variant does come we are
better prepared and more resilient
fifty percent of all eligible canadians
have received a booster dose
55 of all children aged 5 to 11 have
received a first dose
that's good
we must continue
together we can do this and i'll now
turn to doctor tab
bonjour
yes
uh
severe illness trends remain high or are
still increasing in some areas of the
country
however we are starting to see hopeful
signs with weekly reductions reported in
most jurisdictions
compared to last week's update there are
now an average of
1400 fewer people with covert nineteen
being treated in hospitals each day
however
that is still a seven day average of
over eight thousand seven hundred each
day including over one thousand in
intensive care and 130 deaths were
reported daily
as we continue to take measures to
mitigate the ongoing impact of gopher 19
on the health system
health authorities across canada are
looking ahead to longer-term sustainable
management of the sasko v2 virus
this includes transition plans for the
immediate future as epidemiologic
indicators of covet-19 disease activity
continue to improve
this will allow jurisdictions to begin
to ease restrictions
it also includes planning for the months
ahead and beyond when we can expect the
virus to still be with us including
emergence of new variants with uncertain
transmission and severity
characteristics
however what will not change is the
advantage to be gained by maintaining a
state of readiness
this includes monitoring to detect
signals of concern that can enable early
and appropriate public health response
at the population level
at the same time providing guidance and
tools to support risk-based
decision-making can continue to empower
individuals families and communities to
reduce their risk through personal
protective practices
i play long term new proven new fears
is
is
yeah while this has been a long and
difficult journey there's a lot to be
grateful for
reminding ourselves of how we've kept
working together across the country
learned to protect ourselves and each
other in the face of uncertainty and
then adapting to changing circumstances
is a testament to our resilience
more importantly it is a perspective we
need to feel assured that with continued
innovation and creativity we can
successfully adapt and overcome the
challenges ahead
paula momoa
said
evidence shows that two doses of cova-19
vaccines offer reasonably good
protection against severe disease
and receiving an mrna booster dose when
eligible offers superior protection
keeping more people out of hospital and
preventing more deaths
so upon the oncomo vaccine
is
continued
thank you everyone looks like
time for questions as discussed we will
start in the room uh
i'd like to start with kevin gallagher
ctv please
good morning my first question is for
health minister jean-julo and also dr
theresa tam can follow up as well um
given
given this reevaluation it seems that's
happening ongoing as you say for public
health measures and i will lump in their
mandates i i'd like to ask
what
data or studies contributed to
imposing specifically vaccine mandates
in terms of
uh was there any data that showed that
this would be a the best way to increase
uptake of vaccinations especially when
we're talking about people who are
vaccine hesitant or anti-vaxx obviously
i don't need to remark about why i'm
asking this question ottawa has been
occupied by what the mayor's called the
siege by people who have strict and
staunch views against vaccination and
feel that their rights have been
violated in some way by mandates um
i'm not here to necessarily debate
whether the government can put band-aids
in or not but i'd like to know if
there's any data or studies that backed
up the decision to impose them as a way
to encourage people to get vaccinated
and if there's any evidence to show that
that measure would be useful for people
who are already vaccine hesitant or
staunchly anti-vaxx
well thank you for the question i'll
i'll start by saying that
vaccination is not punishment
vaccination is protection in fact it's
it's a protection that
science gave us about a year ago we had
hoped about two years ago that we were
eventually be able to have vaccination
as protection that came enormously
faster than scientists at that time
about two years ago thought it would
come and since about a year now
we have had the gift and the fortune of
being able to vaccinate canadians across
the country so it's not punishment it's
protection for the for the person when i
obviously have been vaccinated i i
receive my booster doors when i do that
it's because i want to protect myself
but i also do that because i want to
protect my family my parents when i go
and visit them my friends when i meet
them and when i see my children be
vaccinated i'm glad for them i'm also
glad for
their friends that he will be or they
will be able to to to be engaged with so
it's not
punishment it's protection the second
thing is about the protection of
vaccination dr tan might
want to summarize the current
knowledge around
biology and immunization but we know as
she summarized earlier that although
it's not perfect it's working but it's
working even more with booster doses and
that's the key message i think that
canadians
will like to hear again today is that a
booster dose is is needed is useful is
important for all
uh eligible canadians and the third
thing is that vaccination mandates work
uh no 99 of public servants have done
the right thing they have been
vaccinated
some estimates
within canada and outside canada suggest
that a large number of canadians are
more
perhaps better able to understand the
value of being protected and to be able
to lead a more normal life through a
vaccination there are some estimates
that it could be up to three million
canadians that over the last six months
because of
mandates and and at the federal and
provincial levels no
trolls to be vaccinated perhaps quicker
and perhaps in in large numbers uh let's
imagine what the situation with omicron
would now be if we had three or up to
three million canadians not vaccinated
with the current uh situation and
finally an alternate doctor tommy ii the
reason for which
an important reason for which we are
moving away from the peak of of omicron
is that
large number of canadians not large
enough still about 50 percent have
received a booster those over the last
few weeks that gave them extra superior
protection against omicron
and in addition to that
that
no people have
have been making the right choice no
they they obviously understood that the
public health measures were there to
protect them we we followed them in
large numbers and that's therefore one
more reason for which we do have this
ability in addition obviously to the
natural immunity that has been
uh created through the large uh
incidents and and and
infections of corvin of corvid 19
some estimates in quebec in ontario
suggested it could be up to about 20 to
25 percent of canadians that have been
infected since the start of omicron in
december so these are large numbers of
people either naturally
immunized or because of vaccination and
and i know i'm speaking a bit too much
perhaps may sound return immediately
then to dr tom
thank you i want to add too much on the
vaccine mandates but there's now
obvious evidence that they they they
work and
i think in the canadian context you can
look at it for individual jurisdictions
uh but immediately after an announcement
uh our faxing mandates
and then the
actual operationalization of them there
was an uptake we saw a plateau in the
uptake of uh vaccines after a really
tremendous effort by canadians
and then after the introduction of
vaccine mandates by the various
departments and territories and
jurisdictions we did see
an uptick in that could be that can be
different between jurisdictions but
there definitely is one and there's
increasing international literature uh
showing that uh mandates
work
but it's not the only tool and it never
has been
for us in public health building vaccine
confidence and trust is the primary
tool
providing the general public with robust
information and trusted messages is
really key
providing access to vaccines really key
because many populations have
difficulties accessing the vaccines
maybe because they work uh different
hours so getting access was very
important reducing inequities
helping debunk misinformation is
extremely important
and i think faculty mandates may
particularly nudge those who are in the
middle trying to figure out whether
they'll get it or not uh has prompted
them to actually get vaccinated
but there was certainly a huge number of
canadians who were very much
supportive of the evidence base
measures uh such as vaccination being a
really incredible tool
i'll just follow up
um you know my question wasn't really
about whether i'm uh i have listened to
many of these press conferences and have
listened to the date about how vaccines
are effective um i understand your point
about how mandates have increased the
vaccination rate in some cases my
question was quite specific about i
maybe i'll just frame it in another way
here
what's the plan to reach out to people
who are so
opposed to vaccination perhaps basing
their information on misinformation as
dr tam just pointed out that they would
be willing to you know pretty much put
their lives on hold to paralyze the
nation's capital
what is the best method to reach out to
some people who seemingly don't trust
the opinions of dr tam don't trust your
opinion health minister
um and have lost faith frankly in in my
reporting and other of my colleagues in
the mainstream so-called media right so
what is the moving forward is should
there be a different approach or tactic
or for reaching out to people who are
staunchly anti-vaxxed and very much
opposed to mandates or vaccinations in
general
well this is a great question i would
separate the answers in two parts first
benevolence and and second trust i think
we we want to speak benevolently about
the about vaccination it's again there
to protect people it's not there to
punish people and in speaking about uh
about that the the benevolent value of
vaccination the good because benevolent
means you want good uh i suppose it's
from latin uh so uh you want to want
good for others and i think it's it's a
language that not only unites people but
as you said brings people forward
now on trust uh i agree there is a lot
of disinformation around all sorts of
things including around the benefits
of vaccination but i'll turn to dr tam
quickly because p hack has obviously in
collaboration with many many partners
many of them
at the provincial and territorial levels
uh pihac
did uh
succeed in providing both the the
benefit the the value the benevolence of
vaccination and also decreasing the
disinformation to which you alluded dr
tam would you like to
give a few examples of how p hack does
that
yes i think
recognizing that not everyone listens
necessarily to government sources or
indeed some
other really incredible expert panels
such as national advisory committee on
immunization we funded a whole range of
uh projects that enable um other leaders
leaders in the community elders
religious leaders uh are supported in
the way that they can uh further support
their own communities black canadians um
and other communities who quite frankly
had lots of reasons to be distrustful of
government and authorities they've been
brought along to get vaccinated because
of the trusted voices in their own
communities and that has got us to this
far as canada having one of the best
vaccination rates in the world but there
will always be a small percentage of
people who will not
essentially take up the vaccine
no matter what we do and that has been
observed in a multitude of vaccination
campaigns and that is probably to be
expected that some people will not
change the minds but because so many
people the vast vast majority of people
haven't been vaccinated we are able to
move forwards in our transition
to be able to manage this virus and
covert 19
in a more adaptable and sustainable way
before we turn to the next question i
just should insert one thing i i'm aware
that uh i believe mr duklow may have to
leave in about 15 minutes and uh we have
other questions in the room but we have
some frank phone reporters on the on the
line i've i have an obligation to take
the questions in the room first but
if if if we uh show a little more v
tests we might be able to get all
questions in both languages and before
you go thank you uh david aiken global
thank you david aiken global and i'm
going to stick to uh english my other
official language is not so good i'm
afraid
a question uh first for dr tam and then
i'd like to hear minister duklow
through this pandemic when we've
instituted border measures it's been
very clear that one of the goals of any
border measure was to reduce or prevent
transmission
so dr tam to the extent we're testing
and tracing
can you tell us and set the stage what
data do we have that any new
transmission in canada is a result of
travel if i could get you to speak to
that and then if you could follow up
minister to say
as you consider lifting border measures
or changing them next week
are you still worried about transmission
from travelers just transmission right
now at this point
yes so one of the uh objectives
particularly when new variants emerge is
to reduce importation risks which could
then lead to transmission
so we do know that the positivity rate
as one might expect with omicron surge
for example has led to a very high
positivity rate in travelers that we
could detect as they come across the
border because of the post arrival
testing uh they surged uh two very high
levels um at the
end of december beginning of january and
then just beginning to come down
but the the positive to rates i'm sure
the minister will speak to that it was
was actually extremely high and each one
of these individuals can potentially uh
transmit to others but not because they
they they want to but because this virus
is so uh difficult to manage and can
transmit even before someone has has um
symptoms so by providing uh testing but
also the
quarantine and isolation measures that's
are there to try and reduce that but we
know that that's not a perfect system
and
because of the nature of omicron and how
infectious it is
it's very difficult to prevent every
case of importation and then onward
transmission
provinces have demonstrated how the
initial introduction have spread of
course first to household members but
then even unbeaten known to them they've
gone to school or work and have
transmitted thereafter but we do have to
adapt our border stance because we know
it's pretty impossible to reduce every
single case of importation it's already
in canada and it's
transmitted widely throughout our
communities but we do still have to look
out for other variants and new variants
and try and detect them as early as
possible and reduce their potential
impact at least to slow slow them down
so that we can understand them better
yes thank you i may add briefly that
we've all learned that the virus uh
spreads through contacts no
the reason for which the virus moves
that people are in contact with each
other and and traveling is obviously one
way through which we may be in contact
with others so the objective is to
protect people against the risk of being
in contact with other infected people
uh
dr tam mentioned those statistics that
you can find on the web the p hack site
website is is accessible if you look at
the most recent statistics you'll see
that the
positivity rates of travelers
entering into canada in january
ranges between six and nine percent uh
despite having those travelers
showing showing a negative
pre-departure
test so
six to nine percent positivity rates
among travelers entering into canada and
that's why as we think thoughtfully
but obviously uh clearly with the
assistance of public health about the
multiple layers of of measures that we
want to have to protect people both
across the borders and in other ways
as well of trains in canada the public
service as i mentioned so as we thought
i would think carefully about those
multiple layers
the overall objective will always be to
protect the safety and the health of
people and we look forward to further
guidance on that
thank you and then just to follow up
minister to close border measures are
often implemented sometimes with our
international partners sometimes not
we've coordinated with the americans
sometimes not can you speak to are we
being held up by
uh because we need to negotiate with the
americans say on cross-border traffic
that way are we going to act
unilaterally can you give us a sense of
discussions you you may have had or the
government may have had with
international partners on changing
border rules
well two or two objectives here that's a
great question the first one is
obviously to serve canadians and to
protect their health and safety based on
the local epidemiological situation in
canada and the national advice on
from from from the from experts the
second objective is obviously to be as
much aligned as possible with other
partners but we can never be too totally
aligned because as you always we all
know the situation uh changes is you
know it comes in waves at different
times across different places so these
two objectives uh reinforce each other
always a protect the safety and and
health of canadians and be do this uh to
the best extent possible with uh
international partners
um this is for the ministers perhaps uh
mr duclow you're in the room but perhaps
minister leblanc
uh how will the new ontario state of
emergency powers help clear the
ambassador bridge
and end the protest in ottawa and why
did it take two weeks
to see that what have you been doing in
the meantime to get to this point
well i'll turn immediately to to
minister leblanc i don't know if dominic
is a doctor but he's certainly a
minister and dominica has been extremely
engaged
with many and as you will indicate in a
moment and we'll have something to say
i'm sure
so mercy thank you
jaive
we have been working
in a collaborative way with the
government of ontario with premier ford
and his ministers
obviously since the beginning
of the occupation
in ottawa the prime minister spoke with
premier ford
i believe on wednesday evening
i spoke with the premier
late last evening on thursday evening
he was still at his office working on
the details
of these emergency measures that he
announced this morning
we think that's a very very positive
step from the government of ontario we
think that that will
help
uh remove the illegal blockades at
border crossings that have threatened
not only the canadian economy but
thousands of jobs that depend on that
very active cross-border trade
and obviously we remain
very concerned and very engaged on the
unacceptable
and illegal occupation in the city of
ottawa i was in ottawa all this week
and i can understand the frustration
of the people who live and work in the
city of ottawa
we think that the measures that the
ontario government announced
particularly
economic measures punitive economic
measures
for people who use trucks
in a way that is illegal and disruptive
to public safety
and to the economy of the country
um we think that this is a very very
important and welcome step that the
government
of ontario took today and my discussion
with premier ford is how we can continue
to work with them and support them
and their law enforcement authorities in
any way possible uh because these
blockades need to be removed uh and need
to end
and obviously the occupation the city of
ottawa uh is in the same category
specifically does this new power give
law enforcement to end these blockades
especially given
i mean there were calls from the united
states government for canada to do
something with the ambassador bridge
isn't that just a little bit
embarrassing what do they specifically
are they going to do what is why is it
and why did it take so long
well
i think obviously the prime minister uh
his officials the national security and
intelligence adviser to the prime
minister
have been in touch with their
counterparts in the united states uh
government there have been
obviously conversations with the
governor of michigan as well
um so we have been very engaged with our
american partners because we share
their very real frustration with these
illegal and unacceptable blockades
because somebody doesn't agree with a
particular public
health measure
doesn't entitle them to damage hundreds
of millions of dollars of cross-border
trade
or uh create enormous disruption and
abuse
uh on the streets of of
the uh of the nation's capital uh that
is not the way to have a thoughtful
discussion about evolving public health
measures
so we certainly share the frustration
that premier ford expressed this morning
this has been an ongoing collaborative
effort with the government of ontario
and other provincial governments
since the moment these illegal
activities began so what you're seeing
now from our perspective is a very
important
series of additional steps that the
government of ontario is putting into
place and as the prime minister has said
in numerous
conversations with
uh provincial counterparts and my
federal cabinet colleagues have been
obviously in touch with their provincial
counterparts not just in ontario but
across the country
the government of canada will be ready
to do whatever we can to support local
and provincial law enforcement
authorities
to make sure that these illegal
activities come to a conclusion quickly
hi uh dylan robertson won a pig free
press question from administer duklow i
wanted to ask about the take home pcr
testing program at the border we've
interviewed rural manitobans who have
had couriers and taxi cabs drive as long
as 10 hours to go pick up a single
sample
this is likely costing upwards of a
thousand dollars each time your
department seems to have no issue with
this is this a prudent use of taxpayer
funds
thank you for the question uh i limit my
answer to two things here we have
obviously a big country or people live
in very different places and sometimes
quite far away from urban centers but
everyone has a right to receive the same
quality of services it's the foundation
of all the broad health care agenda the
second thing is that
given that not our suppliers p-hac
suppliers have been told that they need
to do what is needed to do to provide
everyone with the
the level of service that they need and
deserve and that's for them to decide
on the way in which that has to be done
thank you minister and uh minister
leblanc the manitoba government says
that your government's tone is making
things worse and inflaming things they
argue that the convoy that's blocking
manitoba's main crossing with north
dakota wouldn't be so dramatic if you
had a more measured tone do you accept
that you're making this problem worse
for the provinces
i think as as my colleague jeane duklow
made clear
the decisions that we make and the
measures that we have taken from the
beginning of the pandemic
have been guided by the best medical and
scientific advice
that we have available
as a government and with international
partners dr tam
obviously speaks with her counterparts
uh in other jurisdictions across the
country but uh around the world as well
so
that has to be the basis uh for
governmental decisions
um if a bunch of people are unhappy or
disagree with the science
uh or decide that they're not
uh going to follow the best public
health advice
that they can be given
and decide to undertake an illegal
blockade of a border crossing like in
emerson manitoba or occupy the downtown
core of ottawa
that doesn't actually constitute medical
advice or a clinical trial it is a
disruptive
illegal practice
that harms uh uh thousands and thousands
of canadians
uh who want to do the right thing
uh want to manage the risks of covid but
want to be able to go to work safely
want to be able to operate uh small
businesses um so
the tone uh is also commensurate with
the frustration that businesses feel
that residents feel
by these continued continued illegal
blockades so uh our measures will always
be based on the best public policy
scientific and medical advice
uh that we can that we can receive as
jaiv
duclo and dr tam said they will evolve
over time
as was always understood based on that
advice uh but the government of canada's
job is to
work with provincial and local law
enforcement partners
and provincial governments as we have
been doing obviously extremely actively
to bring these uh these illegal
blockades to a conclusion as quickly as
possible
okay okay i would like to turn to one uh
questions on the phone uh on francais
julian la pointe radio
to canada questions
higher than the average hospitalization
rates over the past
23 months
even though we're doing business
is
[Music]
we
situation
[Music]
[Music]
uh
due to vaccinations
um
in a number of
the wave is coming to an end
are you in agreement that we need such a
title
he will be received
he
i
and unfortunately there may be more
surprises in the months and uh weeks to
come i know we're over time here we do
have three other questioners including
uh stefan blair
is it possible to have another question
is it possible to field another question
yes mr blade please go ahead
ah
you can hear me i trust
mandate
protections
is
is
vaccines
is
is
business is more fragile
uh
um
i'm i'm told uh mr duklow may have to
leave i just like to stress that we have
questions from global mail and cbc left
here on the line it would be great if
the others have time to take them
i can i'm happy to stay for about
another five minutes i okay i was told
it was over at 12 30 but i could stay
for five more minutes
okay we will i'll i'll i'll try one more
we'll see how fast we can squeeze thank
you i appreciate it uh let's try uh
oh i'm sorry we may have one david
thornton cbc
go ahead please
hi
um dr tam what is our new vaccination
goal now that there are boosters um
is there a new specific goal that we're
trying to hit here
as many people as possible
uh is the goal and i've said it even for
two dozen
shoot for the stars there's no
specific uh levels but you want it to be
really high particularly for the
high-risk groups
um i actually think that the
for the older age groups which are some
of the highest risk the
booster rates are pretty good but there
are still some seniors particularly
those over the age of 60
who still haven't got their boost of
those it's really important that they do
because the booster actually really
increase your
protection against severe outcomes it
can actually also reduce your
risk of
getting infected for a period of time as
well which can be
important during an actual wave
but the durability and the quality of
the immune response against severe
outcomes
is augmented for sure by the booster
dose for the younger population they
there is a gap at the moment and again
whether it's for the personal protection
or for making sure that
we have a health system healthcare
system that's sustainable for all for
all illnesses
um it's a great idea for everybody to
get their boosters when they're eligible
so so does that mean that our goal is
you know 100 vaccination
and if that's the case that would be the
ceiling but what's the floor of that
goal what's the minimum you think we're
trying to achieve here
our goal overall in canada's
pandemic response is to reduce severe
outcomes mobility mortality
and um
while um you know balancing that against
societal disruption
and business confusion and everything
can be maintained better if people were
vaccinated um so i can't really answer
your your question because it's really
as high as possible for
for a while i mean our goals and our
science evolved over time as you all
know we've been bringing you all along
with um
news conferences throughout the past
year
um
and we've had the vaccine there for just
over a year
um there were certainly some initial
goal posts
in terms of getting first and second
doses in
in order to achieve a good level of
individual and population immunity
but what we know is that we can't get
rid of this virus it is going to stay
with us
there may not be such a thing as herd
immunity this is a term that i have not
used for a very long time
um but any vaccination level can help
population levels of immunity um and
we've just got a boost of uh that
immunity as well from those who did get
infected
at least against the omicron virus we
don't know where the virus is going to
evolve
that's the other thing that changes your
vaccination goal posts as well so we
have to keep monitoring the evolutionary
virus do we need to change the vaccine
what will we need to do in the fall so
these are all the different scientific
questions and planning that we need to
do moving forwards as we adapt
to the longer term management of covert
19.
rika walsh called mail
good afternoon um i just wanted to
clarify um
on the border
um
just first of all on on the fact that we
still have an international
sweeping travel advisory in place
including for vaccinated travelers one
of the complaints that we've seen from
protesters is that
um
you know we're sending hundreds of
olympians to the olympics in china
meantime the message to the average
citizen is that it's too dangerous to
travel can you tell me if the travel
advisory still makes sense and how you
explain that disconnect to the average
person watching your press conferences
so shout outs thoughts the leblanc no go
ahead dr tam go ahead yeah so um ask
with everything that's evolving we are
actively examining uh the advice for
travelers
we've never stopped people from leaving
canada but
the
current global
advisory travel advisory is avoid
non-essential travel
uh it doesn't stop
any individuals from doing so but it is
a
um really important
message
when omicron has been surging and still
continues to search throughout the world
but we are actively examining that as we
are doing for
other public health measures
mr leblanc you weigh in on that question
please before i ask my follow-up
sure murica i think my colleague jaiv
duklow indicated at the beginning
of his comments that we would uh have
more to say we hope next week
on the normal evolution of measures
at our borders dr tam just i think
repeated what we've been saying
since the beginning of the pandemic that
we put in place the best measures
possible based on the best medical and
scientific advice we have
uh and they change as the circumstances
or the virus changes
um so i think we may have more to say uh
next week
based again on on that advice and those
discussions i
chair the
federal uh cabinet covet committee we're
constantly discussing
examples of of border measures that are
appropriate based on the context of the
virus at this particular time
so
i i would think america you may have the
chance to see us again next week with
some uh precisions on our border
postures
okay thank you and mr leblanc um we're
seeing a lot of sort of back and forth
and finger-pointing between
ontario and the federal government with
federal sources suggesting ontario was a
laggard and imposing these emergency
measures the ontario government's
pushing back on the record uh why does
this finger-pointing serve um ontarians
who have voted for both your governments
and who
you know both your governments are
accountable to and can you please set
the record straight did ontario refuse
to act on the emergency measures earlier
this week and are they late in imposing
them now
so marika thank you uh as i said i think
uh some moments ago we
view very positively the measures that
the ford government announced earlier
today
the prime minister has spoken with uh
premier ford uh a number of times as
recently as a day and a half ago uh late
last evening i had a detailed
conversation myself again with premier
ford uh that was very constructive and
collaborative we
uh and officials senior officials from
uh my department in the public safety
department the rcmp commissioner with
the opp commissioner
the deputy minister of transport our
minister of transport
um
marika these are ongoing active and very
frequent exchanges
uh as to what can we do collaboratively
together
uh to bring these illegal blockades
and occupations uh to an end as quickly
as possible so
the province properly has a number of
jurisdictional
uh tools that they can bring to bear
on this illegal activity uh the federal
government has some law enforcement
resources that we
will obviously make available to any
reasonable request from local or
provincial law enforcement authorities
uh there are federal intelligence
agencies collaborating
with their provincial and local partners
so i have participated in numerous
conversations many times a day as have
my cabinet
colleagues and the prime minister
himself
uh with our officials and with our
counterparts in ontario
uh particularly but not exclusively in
ontario with the governments in alberta
for example and other provinces who are
understandably concerned about similar
activities that are unacceptable so
we'll continue to do that work
and we view it frankly as essential that
every jurisdiction bring to bear the
maximum
pressure they can to end these illegal
blockades and occupations that
are causing such understandable concern
in communities across the country
we'll do everything we can and today the
government of ontario
took what we think is a very very
important step that we hope
uh will contribute to a rapid
conclusion of
the blockades at the borders and the
unacceptable
occupation of the streets of ottawa
thank you for going into overtime with
us today uh unless you have a final uh
comment thank you messi mig witch